so if we play out Ai and say hey  everyone bad news if you make pictures  to post on the internet in Adobe in 17  years that's been replaced by somebody  just saying make a cow with Sunshine On  It Go and there it is right what I say  though is good news everybody all the  people that have these brilliant ideas  that are doing other things do you know  many people actually have the best ideas  who are cashiers at Starbucks that if  they knew that this technology existed  they would be creative directors  everyone goes right away into like  demonizing technology here this comes  it's going to eliminate Junior  copywriters okay but Junior copywriters  eliminated something too like when  advertising came out what happened to  the salesman if we had no advertising  wouldn't everybody be a Salesman the  answer is yeah it's a game of creativity  getting even more on it becomes more  about the idea than the slog of the  execution